The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK, I hope you
all had a good spring break
and are refreshed.
I spent three days
in DC, brainstorming.
It was pretty good.
So if you recall in the week
before our last lecture,
we were discussing
the wave propagation
in layered structures.
And we spent time in
deriving the reflectance--
reflection coefficient
if I have one layer.
And there are three strategies.
One, physically, what happens
if I have wave comes in?
The first time the wave
meets the interface,
there's reflection.
There's transmission.
Go to the last interface,
reflection, transmission.
So there are an infinite number
of reflection and transmission.
And of course, if
there are absorption
during the propagation of
the wave in the layers,
you will-- the
intensity will be lost.
Otherwise, it's
say-- we wrote down,
the strategy is, you can always
do the plan wave propagation.
And if you can ride
the plan wave form,
you can sum up and do
an infinite series.
So we didn't do that in class.
But that's what the physics is.
And what we spent time is
this so-called resultant wave
method.
We say, OK, let's group
this forward propagating
which has the same phase
factor all into one term.
Except, now we don't have
fixed relation between coming
and out, say, in the
full propagating,
because, you can say,
from the physics there,
it's multiple additions, right?
So we want to find
the coefficients.
And similarly, backward
propagating and we
use the continuity of
the Maxwell equation
at the boundary.
And we derive the expression
for the reflection coefficient.
So that's what we spent time on.
And the third method, which
is a much more general,
it's the transfer-matrix method.
And here, you can say, we're
still distinguishing forward,
backward propagating.
And we're doing
electrical field.
And transfer-matrix
method is writing down
both incident reflected
all group into,
what's the electric
field component?
What's the magnetic
And because, at the interface,
these are continuous,
so it's easy for me to propagate
this through many layers,
as long as I have the
transfer-matrix, right?
That transfer-matrix
is the phase factor.
It's written.
You have a general
form for each layer.
And we have many layers.
It's just a multiplication
of those layers.
So that's actually
most common to use.
And people used
to see very often.
And in fact, thin film
deposition is so common,
anybody of you can
pick up this methods
and do design of
multilayer films
to get desirable properties.
And so that's, in fact--
I tell you that I never really,
seriously took a [INAUDIBLE]
wave class.
That's how I-- where I started.
I read the book.
And you have to
have that patience
to write down all the terms.
And do your [INAUDIBLE].
And get the appreciation
for what's happening.
It's a exercise.
And if you take a square of
this reflection coefficient--
and here, I'm assuming
that it's a real, n1, n2,
n3 is real, because
say, clearly,
if it's a complex number,
r12 is a Fresnel coefficient
for each interface
you can calculate.
So even if it's
a complex number,
you can use all the
complex number operation,
do the square.
But here, because I'm taking
a real so I can actually
write it, just in terms
of the regular square root
of the complex conjugate.
And you can see, now,
what's interesting,
what we want to get
in is the phenomena.
And in my expression
for the reflectance,
I have a cosine 2 phi
term in both the numerator
and the denominator.
So you know, then,
this reflectance
was-- will be a periodic
variant function, because
of this cosine term.
So let's use this
for discussion.
And you can, of course,
use a single layer.
And you take a dR, d phi, right?
This phi 2, you can say,
is really d cosine theta.
It's more like a thickness,
the effective thickness
for the direction
of propagation.
And divide by lambda 0,
so normalized to lamda 0.
And this 2 phi 2 is because
of the round trait right?
If you look at the physics we
have, the reflection is coming,
reflect back.
So it's a forward, backward.
That's a factor of
2 in phase, right?
So if I take this into 0 and
you can find where the maximum,
minimum is, and it happens
when sine 2 phi 2 equals 0.
And for this, we have
different solutions,
whether it's a
maximum or minimum.
So this, of course,
happens when--
if I substitute
the phi 2 is 4 pi--
because that's a factor of 2--
n2, d2, cosine theta 2,
lambda 0 is a vacuum,
equals, say, multiple lamda pi.
That's when sine goes to 0.
M is an integer, right?
But whether it's a
maximum or minimum--
so when m is a odd number
so m equals 2l plus 1
and say odd number.
And in this case, I list
that when theta equals 0,
you will find that
reflect test is
m1 n3, mass n2 square and m1,
n3, plus n2 square, square.
So that's an interesting
expression, right?
Emittance, if I have those
conditions met at [INAUDIBLE]
incidence here--
there are also other
angle where you
can write the maximum, minimum.
I'm here writing this, because
this expression is simple.
You can see that, if
I choose-- if I have--
how I do antireflection
coating, right?
I have a surface.
And I don't want the
reflecting-- any reflection.
And then, in this case, I
add a layer in between n2.
And you can say, well, n2 is
the square root of m1 and 3.
You've got a 0
reflection, right?
So by using the
interference phenomena,
this is a-- the periodic
variation of reflectance
is the interference phenomena.
Interference of light, you
can have maximum reflection,
a minimum of reflection, right?
And when m equals 2l, in
this case, what happens is,
again, I say it equals 0.
You'll say your reflectance is
m1 minus n3, m1 plus n3 square.
What does it tell you?
It tells you, even though
you put the layer there,
it doesn't matter.
It's just like an interference
between 1 and 3, right?
So you use this effects to do
different optical coatings.
And here, of course, we're
only talking about one layer.
And you can coat many layers
to have desirable properties.
And people do that
for many applications.
I'll mention more as we go on.
So this is just a
simple, say, example.
One important characteristic
we'll learn from this
is when we consider a wave.
And here is phi 2, right?
If you look at
reflectance and what
you have is, say, a periodical
variation of reflectance,
that's the interference
phenomena, right?
If you go to clean room, you
deposit a layer of film--
very often, some of you may
go in the clean room, deposit
a layer of film.
And experienced person will
look at the color of it,
because of the light,
white light comes
in is a broadband white light.
And because of the
interference effect,
that some color is reflecting
more, some color reflect less.
And if you do a lot of
this, you get experience.
You can tell from the
color, what's the thickness
range you have, OK?
And, of course, the same film,
if you look at different angle,
you see different color.
And again, that's because,
if you look at phi 2,
it's angle dependent.
The phase of the light is, say--
it depends on the trajectory
it propagates in the material.
So this is a one layer film.
And then we will go
multilayer, right?
It's hard to predict when
you add many, many layers
so the interference phenomenon
becomes very complicated.
And by, say, one special
multilayer is this--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, which values
of m correspond to minimum
and which one to maximum?
GANG CHEN: Which value of
M, so here, you can say,
when this we have
here it is the--
this one is the minimum, right?
And this one, I think,
is the maximum, OK?
So when I have
multilayer of the film,
one special case is the
quarter of wavelengths.
So when the tiers of layers
is, say the path lengths equals
quarter of wavelengths-- so what
I have, when I have multilayer,
you can choose a
layer one, layer two.
And you're repeating, layer
one, layer two, right?
And, in this case,
when I have 4 pi,
m1, d1, cosine theta
1, over lambda 0,
plus 4pi n2, d2, cosine
theta 2, over lambda 0.
And this is the effective
layer one and layer two, right?
When they are effectively
equals 2l pi, I have--
in this case, the reflectance
actually reach a maximum.
So what happens is,
if you look at your--
as a function of for,
you can combine these two
as your effective phase,
let's say, effective phase.
Or you say you can change
either wavelengths of light.
If you make your structure
ready for different wavelengths
and would you see reflectance
have the almost perfect
reflection region, OK?
And this is a 1.
This is a 0.
And when it's a
perfect reflection,
that means the light comes
in 100% reflected, right?
And what emits
light is not allowed
in this periodic layer at this
angle of incidence, right?
And so, in optics, this
is called the stopband.
And in solid states, for
electrons and photons,
we call it the Band gap.
If you recall when we discussed
the three dimensional crystals,
the semiconductor
band gap, that's
when the wave
functions of electrons
are not allowed in
this range of energy.
So you can say, I mentioned
before, for optics, people,
the research direction
is going from 1D to 3D.
These object coatings, people
have developed over 100 years.
You'd rather have [INAUDIBLE].
That's only 86.
He said, OK, let's do
3D analogy to crystals,
so that these stopbands
happens in all directions,
so that you can put
a real band gap.
When you have such a crystal, no
matter which direction of light
you shine onto it, it's
all reflecting, right?
So that's why I joked before.
I had a colleague
before was saying,
this is not photonic reflector.
It's a Bragg reflector,
because this quarter
of wavelength stack is
called a Bragg reflector.
And this is the Bragg condition.
We talked before,
X-ray Bragg condition,
when you have pure [INAUDIBLE]
structure, the wave consoles,
right?
So this is the [INAUDIBLE]
in Bragg condition.
And this is a Bragg reflector.
So it turns out, if you have
such a periodic structure,
no matter how small, it's
refractory in that contrast.
When I say, no matter, as long
as you have refractive index
contrast, right?
It can't be just no
contrast at all, right?
You can build many layers
and have such a phenomenon.
So normally, sometimes
when people make, say,
we want high reflection and
they don't have the material
that they get y interface,
y interface reflectance
isn't here, right?
You're limited by the
refractive index contrast.
So what you do is you use
multilayer Bragg reflectors
and make a multilayer structure.
And there are many,
many examples people
using those kind of effects.
One is a semiconductor laser.
So some of the
semiconductor lasers
are actually made out for
gallium arsenide, aluminum
arsenide, right?
So while this-- normally,
a semiconductor laser
has two configuration.
One is the [INAUDIBLE] meeting.
So this is a quantum well.
We mentioned this
configuration before.
Quantum well, typically, very
thin, [INAUDIBLE],, so the light
will go much wider region.
So you use a total
internal reflection.
You put the aluminum
gallium arsenide
in the surrounding, which
has a lower refractive index.
And in that case, the
light is in this region.
And they propagate.
They come out from the
edge of the crystal.
And the light needs
to be amplified.
So it needs to go
a certain distance,
because the laser is an
amplified light emission,
right?
So the amplification is
a positive absorption
coefficient.
We had, before,
absorption coefficient.
The light is decaying
exponentially.
And if you amplify the
growing exponentially--
but you need a certain
distance to grow.
So in this [INAUDIBLE] laser,
the distance for the light
will oscillate.
It's typically a
few hundred microns.
And so, it has the--
because of the-- what
they do is, after they
grow, the same device,
they will cleave it,
naval artillery interface,
between air and
the semiconductor.
So the light comes to the end.
They will be reflected.
And that's the
reflective, right?
If a reflectance-- if the
refractive index number tiered,
typically, it's 3 to 4
gallium arsenide, right?
You can go to say that
reflectance is about, what?
If it's 3, that's
one quarter a square.
It's not big, right?
So they need a long
distance to amplify.
But people don't like
this configuration,
because they have to cleave with
a light to come from the edge.
And people spend a lot of
time trying to grow this,
so that light can come
perpendicular to the surface.
In that case, this is
the quantum well region.
And they have to make
this certain thickness,
half wavelengths or
full wavelengths, OK?
So that's a cavity.
But the light only travel a
very short distance, right?
So in this case, you
need multiple bounce.
You need a high reflectivity,
so that the light is bouncing
back and forth gets amplified.
And together, high
reflectivity they
will deposit this
Bragg reflector
on the top and bottom, middle
gallium arsenide, aluminum
arsenide.
So in that case, after,
say, the reflect inside
the surface can get over 99%.
And the light comes
to some of the light
coming out perpendicular
to the substrate.
So this is a VCSEL, Vertical
Cavity Surface Emitting
Laser, ok?
So in fact, this is
what got me interested
in this multilayer
structure when
I was first doing research.
I was aware that heat cannot
get out, because, in fact,
those weeks when they were
conceived in the 1970s,
it was only until 1990s they
start to be able to sell it,
because of heating issue there.
And when-- first,
when light goes
through those
multilayer structures,
they have to put a charge
going through that structure.
And this becomes very
electrically resistive.
And it turns out,
also, I started
realizing that the
heat also has trouble
to go through those
multilayer structures.
So that's why I worked on
it when I was doing my PhD.
So that's the Bragg
reflector, right?
And if you use--
for example, in your
lab, sometimes you
buy an interference filter.
And interference
filter is typically
also made of Bragg reflectors.
And sometimes a
laser wavelength,
like you want to distinguish
different wavelengths,
they all made of
Bragg reflectors.
Another example, interesting
example of this multilayer, not
necessarily periodic structure,
is the selective surface.
And when I say
selective surfac e,
I mean wavelength
selective service.
And one example is in the
solar thermal collectors.
You want the surface
absorb some radiation.
But you do not want the surface
to radiate heat out, right?
So they-- so ideally,
what you want--
because the solar radiation is
limited to about 2.4 microns.
So wavelengths of
solar radiation
is typically less
than 2.4 microns.
And you want this, ideally,
absorb emissivity course of 1
for this wavelength.
But emissivity
equals 0 beyond that.
When you heat up an object, you
think about Winslow lamda t,
about 3,000.
So if your object is 500 Kelvin,
your wavelengths is 10 micron.
That's the peak wavelength.
So the [INAUDIBLE] body emission
from the surface is here.
So if you can minimize
the emissivities to 0,
you don't lose this
much here, right?
So that's what the
selective surface--
ideally, I want the
emissivity 1 and 0 here
and how you make it, right?
You look at, say--
typically, what is a surface
that's a good reflector?
That means the-- its
remittance is going to be low.
Typically, metal is a
good reflector, right?
And if you take a copper, you
take aluminum, they're shiny.
If they're shiny, that's--
again, you can calculate now.
Using the Fresnel
formula, you'll
get a refractive index
or optical constants.
You can calculate it.
But the emittance of
metal is typically low.
The problem is, absorptions
is also low, right?
So what people do is they
typically take this metal.
And they will coat a few layers.
And this, you have to optimize.
Computer code, you
optimize different
of the refractive index.
And [INAUDIBLE] this way,
the coat is aluminum.
They start with
aluminum substrate.
And they coat--
they change the--
I think, it's the nitrogen
environment or oxygen
environment, right?
They change of the
oxygen pressure.
So now, it's together.
You get the aluminum
oxide, aluminum mixture.
And if you change that
pressure, you'll--
each layer, you can actually
have a different mixture.
And that way, they can
do it really cheap.
And the performances
are pretty good.
They can gather
emissivity, typically,
around the 95% in this--
the solar range and the
emittance in the infrared range
as low as 5%, with three or
four layer coating, right?
I went to those companies
that do this kind of coating.
And their vacuum chamber
is as a football field.
And they're doing this, because
in China, this is, actually,
a really low, widely
used solar thermal
in many, many households,
over 100 million square meters
deployed, right?
They do it really cheap, right?
So you have to look
at those coatings.
And of course, when
you think of energy,
you have to look at your cost.
But what I want to tell
you is, now, you can do it.
Using that transfer matrix,
it's a computer optimization.
It's the one material you
choose that's realistic, right?
And if you design
that-- there are
a lot of coating
companies outside that
will be happy to do it for
you, if you have the money, OK?
And let's-- so this is
a-- we have, really,
the optical single layer
on multilayer calculation.
We can do it now.
And to continue the
discussion, what I want
is to look at the case
when the angle of incidence
at the first layer is larger
than the critical angle
of incidence, right?
So in this case, at
a single interface,
we know there's a total
internal reflection, right?
But all the formula we learned--
for example, here, this
formula is still valid.
The only thing I
assume here is real--
but say, if it's a complex,
you can use complex number.
And if it's angle larger
than angle of incidence,
you can still use that formula.
The math part is identical.
So what's interesting is,
when the angle of incidence
is larger than critical angle,
what I have is, cosine theta 2.
You can say, cosine, theta 2
is 1 minus sine theta 2 square,
right?
Sine theta 2, using
Snell law, is one minus--
OK, let's say, sine
theta 2 square.
And theta 2, sine theta 2
Snell law is sine theta 2, n2
equals m1, sine theta 1, right?
So you can see, in
this case, I have
sine theta 2 is larger than
1 above the critical angle.
So when I do my
cosine [INAUDIBLE],,
1 minus sine theta 2 square,
I get the imaginary number.
And that's what we
discussed before.
We have even less than
wave on the other side.
So if I have one
single interface,
this everlasting wave decay
exponentially and doesn't
carry energy to the other side.
But-- so if I do this, what I
write is m1 sine, theta 1, n2 ,
square minus 1.
I put that say, this now
becomes a real number.
And you can see, my cosine
theta 2 is an imaginary number.
If I substitute into--
this imaginary number
into here, now you
will see my reflectance
is no longer 1.
It could be long.
Say, it could be
less than 1, right?
And similarly, your
transmittance is no longer 0.
So this is what happens.
The optical tunneling-- so this
is the tunneling Phenomenon.
So what happens, physically,
is, I have a high index
material, m1, right?
And you shoot the light
above the critical angle.
And normally, it's
totally reflected.
But on this side, there
is exponential decay
everlasting wave.
And now, if-- here, if you see
ib, cosine theta is i times b,
you can say, of course, that
depends on b times d2, right?
Otherwise, that's
exponential decay.
It's an exponential function.
And if this is really small,
that reflectance is what?
If this exponential term really
small, all this drop out,
that's still what?
And when the-- say, this
one, phi 2, d2 times that b,
divided by lambda,
it's not that, say--
it's very small, actually.
Very-- it's very
large, it dropped to 0.
But when it's very small,
I can actually, now,
have the reflectance
that's less than the--
say, it's no longer 1.
So that's the tunneling.
So what happens is,
this everlasting wave,
when I bring a [INAUDIBLE]
surface close by--
so this is n2.
This n2 could be vacuum.
For example, I put a glass.
I put the vacuum.
I put another layer
of glass, right?
And this, when I bring it close,
this wave start propagating
again, it's allowable
because of the angle--
Schnell law in the third medium.
The angle, if I use the Schnell
law, is ly sine theta 1.
n2 sine theta 2 already
says about critical angle.
But the n3 sine theta 3.
And in this medium, it
could be propagating, right?
So in this case, what I'll
I have is R not equal to 1.
And transmittance
is not equal to 0.
So I have final
transmission of tunneling
of this evanescent wave.
So tunneling of-- and if you
look at-- the distance for that
to happen is when the separation
or the thickness of the film
is comparable to wavelengths.
That's an exponential
function, all right?
So that gives you the
order of magnitude.
So this tunneling phenomena
is valid for all waves, right?
All those interference
phenomena, tunneling phenomena,
Bragg reflectors.
Bragg reflector-- in
the case of electron,
it's the superlattice.
You read [INAUDIBLE] paper.
That's a superlattice for
going from 3D to 1D, right?
So all these are
applicable for as long
as you treat them as waves.
So just whether it's a
scalar wave for electron
and a transverse wave for
vector wave for [INAUDIBLE]..
And the acoustic wave is
more complicated, right?
Longitudinal and transverse.
So if this is tunneling of
evanescent wave for photon,
there is corresponding--
you can do all the analysis
as we did for electron.
So electron-- what we had before
is, at one single interface
when wave comes in,
you have reflection.
You have transmission, right?
And if the energy is less
than the barrier height,
you have total reflection, OK?
But you have an evanescent
wave function on this side.
And so again, if I
put a very thin film--
and so this is my structure.
Sandwich structure-- layer
1, layer 2, layer 3, right?
So electron wave
launched from layer 1.
And if the energy is less
than the barrier height
U0, if this is the
energy of the electron--
so in this case, I have
an evanescent wave.
But if my layer
2 is thin enough,
you can come out and
become propagating
into the third medium.
So that's determining
of electron.
And you could use, again,
the same analysis--
similar analysis-- we
do for the optical wave.
And this is a scalar wave.
It's easier.
You'll get the transmittance--
for electrons in this case,
it's a 4E energy U0 minus
E and 4E U0 minus E plus U0
squared sinh function square
D and 2m U0 minus E and h bar
square.
So this is the transmittance.
And typically, the sinh function
is exponential function.
So it grows large.
So the first tau
term can be dropped.
If you do that, if you
then, say, [INAUDIBLE]
the exponential, this one
will be 16E U0 minus E over U0
square exponential 2 K2 d.
K2 is what we have
in this bracket.
And that's the wave vector
in the second medium.
OK.
So we gave the order of
magnitude of this before.
But let's do it again.
We said, for optical
waves, the tunneling
happened when the thickness
is comparable to wavelength.
So if I do thermal radiation, my
wavelength's around 10 micron.
And that thickness
is 10 micron range.
You start to have tunneling.
But for the electron
wave, this K2
is 2m U0 minus E h bar square.
That's magnitude.
So if we go to estimate
again-- so here,
the electron mass 9.1
10 to the minus 31.
So if this U0 minus E is
about 1 electron volts
order of magnitude, it's
1.6 10 to the minus 19.
And h bar is 1 10
to the minus 34.
So square 68.
So this one, I
will get 6 then 10
to the 9th inverse Armstrong--
or no, inverse meter.
So you can say, essentially,
when K times D--
when D is of the order of 1
Armstrong 10 to the minus 10,
my exponential is pretty
appreciable, right?
So in the case of
electron tunneling,
that happens in the
Armstrong range.
In the case of photon
tunneling, happens
of the order of, say,
optical wavelengths,
say thermal wavelengths, right?
[INAUDIBLE] the radiation peak
at 300 is about 10 microns.
So it's a very different scale.
But the physics is all similar.
So there are really a
lot of interesting ideas
using those phenomena.
I told you before, this Binnig
when he interviewed at the IBM,
right?
So he was asked to
think about the idea
to measure roughness of the
surface down to Armstrong,
right?
So he did this using this idea.
So this is layer 1, a probe.
Layer 2 is a vacuum.
Layer 3 is the surface you're
going to measure, right?
And you apply a bias voltage.
And you scale over the surface.
You measure current.
You use your current
[INAUDIBLE] feedback.
That's tunneling, right?
So if your current--
based on the current
and your feedback,
you can maintain your
height, not crash your T.
So of course, they say,
they did the experiment.
It worked.
But then, they
actually didn't know
where the tunneling
happened, because this
is atomic scale, right?
If you look at the probe,
they will cut the metal
and cut a sharp
tip or [INAUDIBLE]..
So there are a lot of papers--
where this tunneling really
happened.
And you magnify the probe.
Eventually, there is
one atom in the front.
And that's probably where the
current goes through, right?
And so Binnig got a
lower price for this.
But they say, a lot of you use
atomic force microscope, right?
That's also his invention.
This was what he
did at IBM Zurich.
And he went to Stanford
for sabbatical.
But everybody was asking how
to measure insulators, right?
This was a limit
to the conductors.
So I read one of his articles.
He said one day he was sick.
He was lying in his apartment
and looked out the roof
and came up with this idea
of atomic force microscope.
Why?
Because there is
always fundamentally--
he said the thinking is,
OK, you have a solid.
And you have cantilever, right?
And your first
question, he say, is,
I'm going to scratch the
surface or not, right?
If you use a cantilever
on the surface,
you're worried about
that you scratch
the surface, how you're going
to measure atomic roughness.
But he now said, this is
where the basic knowledge--
this spring constant, right?
So you know the vibration.
You know the spring
constant between atoms.
And you go to see--
you go to look at,
what's the spring
constant of cantilever?
What's the spring
constant between atoms?
And the atom's spring
constant is much stiffer.
That means the cantilever
will bend, right?
The stiff one moves less.
So people think of this idea.
That's because we
have the knowledge.
You have to apply your knowledge
and think about this-- this is,
say, possible, right?
So he has this.
And of course,
there is deflection.
So he knows how to
measure deflection,
because he put a scanning
tunneling microscope here.
That cantilever
itself is a conductor.
So if you look at how the
AFM-- at the beginning,
it was the AFM, atomic
force cantilever
plus a scanning tunneling tip
to measure this deflection
of the cantilever.
Later on, people said, OK, there
is a much easier way to do it.
And that's by
optical deflection.
Because optical deflection is
magnifying the small change
in the height into angle.
Angle times this
distance is a magnifier,
because that's more angle
if you magnify the distance.
You put a position detector.
And you measure this voltage
change at different positions.
So that became much
easier to implement.
So you've got to
have your knowledge,
and you've got to be creative.
Sometimes, you also have
to have a break, right?
OK.
That's electron
tunneling, right?
And the photon tunneling-- you
can easily think of the same.
So there are people
who developed
the different way of a
photon tunneling microscope.
One way is-- this is a prism.
You launch the light
perpendicular to the surface.
So there is no total
internal reflection.
But at this surface, there is
a total internal reflection.
So here-- your reflected
light, your wave.
It has an evanescent wave here.
And OK.
Now, you bring a surface.
That's a vacuum.
It's layer 2.
You bring your third
layer, which is a probe.
You brought it close.
That will interact with
this evanescent wave
and scatter them into
propagating wave.
So that's ways people do--
in fact, I think Professor
Peter Shor in the department,
he will do this to try to
image, a say, nanoparticle
or biological
object with under--
say, try to be the
optical resolution,
the wavelength limit, right?
There are different
ways to do it.
But sometimes, there are
also crazy ways to think.
Let me give you an
idea that didn't work.
I don't think it worked.
And there was a big
project by DARPA
trying to do the tunneling
energy conversion.
And so basically, you
heat up a surface.
This is T hot.
This is T cold, right?
And they want to bring
the two surfaces really
close so that electron
from the hot side
tunneled to the cold side.
And you'd have power
generation, all right?
There's a company.
You can search the web.
It's called Cool Chips.
It's still there.
And they want to
do cooling also.
You apply current.
And you go tunnel electron
from one side to the other.
Principle-wise, it's all fine.
But doing a thermal
system with two fields
of Armstrong-level separation,
you screwed most of the time,
right?
The contact kills you, right?
And in fact, I say
there is also--
even last week, I
was in a workshop.
Some people were mentioning our
work, because they want to do--
this was a Stanford group.
They want to do the tunneling--
the thermionic emission, right?
Thermionic emission is a
[INAUDIBLE] work function,
right?
The few electron volts--
so if you heat up electron,
heat up the object,
the electron will evaporate
physically out of the surface,
right?
That's thermionic
emission, right?
So the problem is that when
you have two surfaces close-by,
and--
say not close-by, far apart.
When electrons go out,
they create a potential.
Because a charge in a
vacuum has the potential.
The other electron now
will see that potential.
It's hard to get
to the other side.
So that's a space charge effect.
So their theory-- and
this Stanford group
was also doing this.
They said, OK, we're doing MEMS
fabrication to make it smaller.
So the reduced space charge
effect, which is fine.
But then, when people say,
OK, why don't you do this?
They say, oh, Gang
Chen has a study.
Because when you're getting
really close, what happens is,
the tunneling of light actually
increases heat transfer,
which you don't want in
energy conversion, right?
So you don't want to get
the T hot, T cold too close
below micron.
The radiation tunneling
starts to come in and increase
your heat transfer, because
this vacuum is good.
But say, so you have to see,
where is your balance point?
And of course, we do
another experiment.
We do another experiment
where this is T hot.
This is T cold.
And we are starting
the radiation transfer.
That's when the two
surfaces get really close.
I can have tunneling.
And that would significantly
[INAUDIBLE] the black body
radiation, OK?
And so this is different.
A lot of very fancy,
interesting physical phenomena
happens at this scale.
And also an interesting
question is asked.
What are you going
to do with it, right?
If you invent this,
it's a great impact.
And some of those
ideas don't work.
But it's good to know
what's the limit.
OK, so what we have done--
if you recall, when
we started chapter 5,
this is the actual chapter I
spent the most time so far,
right?
And what we want to find
out is the transport
between two points--
point 1 and point 2.
And if I know the
transmission tau from 1 to 2,
and I know transmission
from 2 to 1,
and then I know
how many, how much,
how fast I can count to
see, what's the energy flux?
What's momentum flux?
What's the charge flux, right?
You can do those type of
transport calculations.
And what we have done
in the past few lectures
is to see how we calculate
that transmission from one
point to the other,
be it the interface,
be it the many layers, right?
So now, we can
use this knowledge
to put the story together
and write down the transport
formula.
If you recall, so far
we have been doing--
the best, in terms of
the energy, for example,
is the heat capacity,
the energy stored
per unit volume, which
is a density of states
times the number of--
say, particle average
lumber, particle
per states times the
energy per state, right?
So that's how they
integrate together,
get the total energy
per unit volume.
But now, we're looking at the
flux, and then from one point
to the other.
So let's look at this.
And this is the
Landauer formalism.
Landau formalism as the
actual view of transport
is relatively new.
It's much later than others,
like [INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE]
response theory transport.
This was developed in the 60s
and 70s by Landauer at IBM.
And so the basic
idea is what we see.
If I know the
transmission from 1 to 2,
I can count the flux, right?
So let's say I
want to count heat,
because there are
different ways you
can write for different
transport processes.
So from point 1 to point 2,
if I allow the transmission
from point 1 to point 2, and I
can write per mole the energy.
Let's say if the
quantum state energy--
and by point 1, I use
substrate E1, right?
And tau 1 to 2--
say, if I have a
wave where the energy
E1 comes to point 1, how much
is reaching point 2, right?
And if at that quantum state,
how many number of partners I
have.
So I have E1 and TE1.
I use a T temperature,
but I put a substrate E,
because there are
some subtle points
I'm going to comment, OK?
So this is just
one quantum state.
I have not said what's
the speed, right?
It has to have the velocity,
because I'm considered a flux.
So let's say, if this is the Z
direction, so this is a V Z1.
So you can this as a per second
now energy of a quantum state
transmission from 1 to 2.
How many particles in
that quantum state, right?
Now I just need to count how
many total quantum states
I have.
That's what you had before I
summed up all the kx1, ky1,
kz1, and the polarization.
And that's where
you stop, right?
If you can do this,
this is for energy.
Of course, you can
do it for momentum.
You can do the for charge.
You can do it for entropy.
You can do all
transport problems, OK?
So my starting point.
And now, you know once you
start writing this summation,
the best way is converting
into integration, right?
So I can convert.
I say, the way of conversion--
I do want to comment
on difference.
Here, before, when we
did the heat capacity,
which is energy times the F
summed up with the kx ky kz,
right?
Sum of quantum states.
But here, this one can
depend on direction.
Look, when we talk about
single interface, that's
angle-dependent, right?
So I don't have the
angular symmetry anymore.
The velocity could also
be angle-dependent.
So I'm losing the symmetry.
And I have to be careful when I
convert using these substates.
And so I'm going
to write it out.
And let's say polarization.
And of course, k is
a kx quantum state.
It's 2 pi over Lx.
That's the spacing, right?
So I can always
convert integration.
And dkx 2 pi Lx.
And in fact, if I do flux,
I should do per unit volume.
And that will normalize
all this Lx Ly.
And this is dky 2
pi Ly dkz 2 pi Lz.
So this is a converting
the summation points
into integration points.
I have VZ1, tau 1
to 2, f and E1 TE1.
OK.
And here, so
depends on kx ky kz.
And typically, .
This f is a function
of energy, right?
So you have the choice.
Convert everything in
k integration or energy
integration.
You make your choice.
You have the freedom, right?
And I'm going to
convert it into E.
Doesn't mean it's always
convenient using E, OK?
And so I have dkx, dky, dkz.
This is a Cartesian
coordinate, right?
In k space-- not a real space--
k space Cartesian coordinate.
And I do the spherical
coordinate in k space.
So dkx, dky, dkz.
If it's do dkx, dky, dkz,
if a spherical coordinate
is k squared, that's the radius
sine theta dc theta d phi.
That's my conversion
from Cartesian
to a spherical
coordinate, right?
So when you do, for example,
if you translate this
into a problem interface,
your wave comes in, right?
That's your k.
And it has a certain direction.
Theta phi-- you can choose your
theta phi coordinate yourself,
as long as you count
that correctly, right?
So this is what we're
doing, in math-wise.
And if I do this--
before, again, if
you think about what
we had for specific heat,
we had a spherical symmetry.
So I can integrate
the theta and phi.
But my problem is, here it's
dependant on theta phi--
tau, right?
I lose my symmetry,
angle symmetry.
So I cannot integrate out
the general expression.
I lost the advantage I had
when I do specific heat.
And when we do specific
heat, we typically
like to do energy integration.
That's why I say
here, it may not
be necessarily you do
energy integration easiest.
You might be doing momentum.
Just do kx, ky, kz.
It's fine.
But I'm used to--
so if you recall what
we had before, we said,
OK, when I do this
summation over, say,
the polarization, whatever
function I'm going to do,
this is f.
Let's say that's the one
that I'm interested in.
And I gather 4 pi k
squared dk, that's
when I had a spherical
symmetry, right?
When I integrate
over theta and phi.
And when I did that,
I converted into--
dk is dk, dE and times dE.
So all this together
plus this together
gives me density of states
dE, if you recall, right?
So if I combine these
density of states,
I got a 4 pi k
squared dk k squared--
oh.
Here, I should have dk.
k squared dk is the
density of state over 4 pi.
OK?
So what I can write, then.
q 1 to 2 equals--
I convert everything
into energy integration.
And phi integration
is 0 2 pi d phi.
So if you look at
this, this is my theta.
My azimuthal plane is 2 pi--
0 2 pi.
And my theta integration
has to be careful,
because what comes
in is a lot longer--
it's the only 0 to 90 degrees.
It's not 0 to 180 degrees.
When I integrated energy, local
energy is 0 to 180 degrees.
But I'm looking
at, only counting
what come towards the surface--
0 90 degrees.
So this is 0 pi
over 2, OK? d theta.
And say, dk becomes dE.
And what's left
in the bracket is
wave Z1 tau 1 to 2 and fE1 TE1
and times the density of states
at E1, right?
So this is dE1.
And this is the energy
spectrum at the point 1.
OK.
So those are the
necessary evils you
have to do when you
deal with transport.
And so the integration
in phase space theta phi,
or k, or E depends
on your choice.
Oh, here.
I'm sorry.
OK, because there is 4 pi.
You recall, because here,
when I convert, this is 4 pi.
I have to divide k squared dk.
I have to divide 4 pi.
OK?
And one further comment.
If you're a true expert on this,
the density of states, in fact,
you can write, it's
an angle-dependent.
If you have an isotropic
crystal in each direction,
you may have different substates
per unit-- so any angle.
OK.
So this is a 1 to 2.
If you can write 1 to 2,
you can write 2 to 1, OK?
q2 to 1 is the same.
I'm not going to repeat.
You change all this stuff here.
I'm going to write it here, OK?
V Z2 tau 2 to 1 f E2 TE2, and d.
And say this is either E2 4 pi.
OK?
Everything, all the
integration is the same.
And you have the
left difference--
q 1 to 2.
Left difference, left flux
is q 1 to 2 minus q 2 to 1.
Mathematically, physically,
conceptually, it's
very easy, right?
It's just the difference
between the two points.
OK.
Now comes to this
very important point.
You see, if I write
down this minus this,
it's a pretty complex.
Each time I list it, you have
to do 2 times integration, 2
left integration, right?
And you may easily
make mistakes.
And that mistake is, you
may violate second law
when you do so.
So you have to know,
when you do this,
you have to meet the
second law requirement.
The second law will tell
you, if you have both sides
at the same temperature, or you
have the system at equilibrium,
what happens?
It's left to right
equals right to left.
It's as simple as that.
But it's very powerful.
And I actually say some papers
do those kind of integration.
And it is wrong.
Because they violate
the second idea.
And this idea is the second law.
But it's called the
detailed balance.
So principle of
So what it says-- at
equilibrium, and q 12
should be 0.
There's no left flux.
And what goes from left equally
goes from right to left.
It doesn't mean there
is low transport.
It's just a dynamic
equilibrium-- left encompasses
right, right?
And with that, when I rewrite
the difference, I actually,
from 2 to 1--
you say, 2 to 1, 2
point is either t2, E2.
I can write this q 2 to 1
at a different temperature
should equal to 1 to 2 at
the same temperature T2.
So I will write this.
OK, so q 2 to1--
this is, at T2, E2.
And this should equal to,
according to detailed balance,
this should equal to q 1
to 2 at TE2 and E1, right?
Basically, if I just
look at this term itself,
at temperature T2 from 2 to
1, should be equal to 1 to 2
when the one side is also
at the same temperature.
That's detailed balance.
And the beauty of that is,
now if I write the 2 to 1,
everything is the
integration limit.
Everything is in
terms of E1, right?
Follow me.
Let me write down the
final expression then.
If I use this
detailed balance, I
can write what I have for q 1 2.
Now, the left is E1.
Whether you choose
one or two actually
depends on your preference.
It depends on the problem.
Sometimes, it's easier to
get the transmittance from 1
to 2 than 2 to 1.
So this is E1.
And 0 2 pi d phi, and
0 to pi over 2 d theta.
And I have V Z1 and tau
1 to 2, and d E1 4 pi.
And what's the difference now
is that f TE1 E1 minus f T2
E1 dE1.
So I have conveniently used
the detailed balance principle
to write this expression
in terms of only one side--
either side 1 or side 2, right?
And you can see, I
will never violate
the principle of
detailed balance,
because when two sides are the
same temperature, this is 0.
Automatically satisfied.
And I save a lot of trouble.
I don't need to do
two integrations.
I only need to do
one integration.
I don't need to calculate
two coefficients.
And in fact, these
two coefficients
must be related based on my
detailed balanced principle,
all right?
So this is very
subtle, very important.
And let's use this to understand
thermal boundary resistance,
right?
So many of you have heard
thermal boundary resistance.
And now, we understand that when
I have two media, even if they
are perfect interface,
even they are atomic flat,
but if they are two
different materials,
or even same material with a
different crystal graphical
configuration, what happens
is, at the interface, I have,
wave comes in.
I will have reflection.
I have transmission.
Now that, you can calculate.
In principle, you
can calculate, right?
And so I know my tau.
This is 1.
This side is 2.
And I can apply my
expression here.
And to get the heat
flux, it's proportional
to the temperature difference
of the two sides, right?
So in this case, what I have--
remember, if you look at
this, what I'm doing--
this is the photon coming
towards the interface from 1
to medium 2, right?
So this is the corresponding
temperature of this E1.
And I call this, actually,
immediate photon.
This is the incoming photon.
And it's a highly long
equilibrium process
at the interface.
Interface is always
non-equilibrium transport.
There is no-- it's
actually hard to think.
And it's not an
equilibrium path.
And this other side,
I have E2 come in,
reflection and transmission.
So that's what happens.
And based on the
expression I have,
you can say here, if the
temperature difference
on the two sides are
not very different,
I can do a
differentiation of that f.
So I can write this as df dT
times TE1 minus TE2, right?
OK?
And the other T over q is
defined as the thermal boundary
resistance.
So if I have a boundary,
I have reflection,
I will get resistance.
And it's the same
for any material.
If you have charge
reflection, you
get the electron resistance.
You will have, say,
photon reflection,
you get thermal resistance.
And this q 1 2 equals TE1
minus TE2 and R prime.
And let me actually
also put this.
It's RE prime double prime.
That's a specific thermal
boundary resistance.
So the unit here will be
meters squared kelvin per watt
for this.
It's specific per unit area.
So if you you know the area,
you divide it by that, OK?
So here, based on
this, you can say,
I can calculate the thermal
boundary resistance.
E and 0 2 pi d phi 0 pi over 2,
and d theta V Z1 and tau 1 2 2,
and E1 dfdtT.
And then, substates
E1 4 pi and dE1.
So in theory now, you
can calculate this term.
You calculate the substates.
You know this.
You know the band structure.
This velocity, I'll
discuss next, OK?
So you can calculate
everything, right?
But you should ask me a problem.
I'm waiting for the
question to be asked.
You see, there are
some problems here.
That is, if my transmissivity
equals 1, what happens?
If my transmissivity
equals 1, is this 0?
Resistance is not 0, right?
So what's the problem?
In fact, the first paper on
this was written by [INAUDIBLE]..
I think it was a
Stanford professor.
And he had a discussion of this.
Let's see.
He said, what happens if you
have an imaginary surface,
right?
He said, this is not applicable.
You have to do our
[INAUDIBLE] free path.
But then, too,
the problem really
lies in how we
define temperature.
This is a highly long
equilibrium process
at the interface, right?
And temperature is defined based
on more equilibrium concept.
And if we think
about at equilibrium,
the distribution function
is isotropic, right?
There's no direction.
And what happens
at this interface--
if you look at it, I say,
this is the incoming.
This is the other side incoming.
Each side, you have a
different spectrum, right?
You know that this together
gives me the spectrum.
Different energy
distribution, right?
So what I really
say-- what's really
the temperature at this point?
The temperature at the point--
if you think about the local
energy density at a point
gives you the temperature.
If you go back to the
specific heat calculation,
the local energy is relative
to local temperature.
And that local energy is
defined based on all directions.
And when I look at this point,
my energy on the left side--
let's say this is my T1.
This is my T2.
I say it's different
than T1, T2.
That's because when I
look at the point 1,
I have those 4 lines coming in.
That has the
characteristic-- that's T1.
That's only 180 degrees
on this side, right?
That's the incoming.
The other is outgoing.
That's the other 180.
And let's look at this.
This is incoming.
That's this side.
The outgoing on this
side is a reflection
of the surface itself.
So reflection depends on
reflectance and the angle
dependence.
It may not be symmetric at all.
That's one part.
The other part is my
transmission here on this side.
Once it transmitted,
that's again
modulated by my transmission,
which has angle dependence.
So this is the transmission.
So I add these two together.
That gives me-- they go
into other directions.
That's that part.
And then, it may
not completely--
unsymmetric.
And the local energy
should be defined based on,
you add this part, add
this part, add this part.
And divide by if it's the
equivalent temperature, right?
So if you do equivalent
temperature, T!
1 and T2, you redo your energy
balance, it will be different.
Because this T1 clearly
depends on not only
the temperature that comes
in, but also the transmittance
from the other side, right?
So you will have to
write the relation
at the end of your expression.
That's in the book.
I'm not going to rewrite it.
You get a different thermal
boundary resistance.
And the limit when transmission
is 1 is just 0, OK?
I wrote that.
And people typically
don't know it.
So I keep telling my own group,
you need to read my chapter 5.
Because you have to read
carefully to understand that.
Because very often, people
are comparing wrong things.
They do an experiment.
And they will compare
it with this theory.
But what they really
measure is these two.
And you're comparing
apples and orange.
And you see, sometimes, they
have perfect comparison.
You know something's wrong, OK?
But this is not just
this one problem.
Actually, you want to
check the literature.
It's everywhere
people discuss it.
People really do this kind
of research [INAUDIBLE]..
Let me give examples.
And so now you can use
this to understand there
are many interesting phenomena.
What we discuss here is
thermal boundary resistance.
That's where I'm
really interested.
So I spent time on it.
But say in electrons-- so
if you have a wire or a dot,
people do a lot of this
kind of experiment,
where they measure
the voltage here--
V1 and V2-- and
go through a wire.
And when the wire's
very small, it
goes to a very low temperature.
You got quantized conductance.
And that conductance is actually
independent of material.
It's universal.
And same if you do heat
at a very low temperature.
This is all n the book,
the example problem.
You get a universal
heat conductance.
It's the independent
material, OK?
And then, the question
is, there was a question
that often people ask.
If it's a ballistic, why do
you have resistance at all?
Ballistic means to go from
one point to the other.
Why you have resistance at all?
And you see, here is-- those
are the ballistic quantized
conductance, right?
And this really depends
on the definition.
And in the case of your
experiment-- in the case where
people do this
quantized conductance
measurement, for example,
you have a carbon nanotube.
You measure the conductance.
You put two metal
electrodes, right?
And so you have a nanotube.
You put the two
metal electrodes.
And what you measure is not this
temperature or electrochemical
potential.
You're measuring the
[INAUDIBLE] and the source.
This is the average
over a large area.
So what does that mean?
It's what launched it into
this region corresponds
to what you measure.
What's launched is your--
immediately electron.
If you had the chance--
there is a way to measure
exactly the potential here
of incoming plus ballistic
going from this side
to the other side, right?
Then this point and this point--
there is the same potential.
If you use that same potential,
you get infinite conductance,
OK?
So it's really how
you-- because those are
all a non-equilibrium process.
It depends on how you
do your measurement, how
you interpret it.
So in electrical engineering, I
remember I was reading a book.
There was a whole section
devoted to this discussion.
And in fact, you go to check--
once I was looking
into this paper.
Professor Peter [INAUDIBLE]
in the physics department
had a few papers on this
quantized conductance.
Same problem, different fields.
This is just really, you
have to spend your time
to understand it.
Finally, just a another
example for you to think
is, when I have two
black body radiations--
pretend two surfaces, right?
In a vacuum--
T1, T2.
What's the temperature
of photons inside?
There's no equilibrium.
You have two
counter-propagating photons.
They don't interact.
Now, if you have this black
body absorber [INAUDIBLE] disk.
On one side, they absorb T1.
On the other side,
they absorb T2.
So at the end, your
absorbed temperature
will be T force equals T1
force plus T2 force average.
And that temperature
is uniform here, right?
But when you stick
a thermocouple,
you measure this hot side,
you measure another photon
temperature, you measure
solid temperature.
You stick a thermocouple
on this side,
you measure the
solid temperature.
So when you do your
black body, you say, my q
equals sigma T1 force power
minus T2 force power, right?
And correspondingly, you
do your q over delta T.
That's your conductance, right?
It's not infinite.
However, if you are able
to put this detector--
measure this point
and this point,
it's the same temperature.
You should get a
conductance infinite, right?
So it depends on
how you define it.
You have to be careful.
That's my point, OK?
I'll stop here.